hi guys this is andrew for
trainingsenses.com and today i want to
do some technical analysis
on the tags so tesla apple
i think those are the most hot like the
hardest stocks in the market
in the tech market at the moment and
tesla who is making a very strong move
up
after some uh rumors it's not rumors is
that after it was said that it's gonna
enter
finally in the s p 500 so it was up like
i think 12 uh two days ago and
apple uh that is just leading the s p
500 for a very long time
with a market cap of more than 2 000
billion dollars guys more than the
french gdp
you know it's biggest than most of like
the
european markets countries by countries
it's just insane this is one stock guys
bigger than
most of europe indices all right let's
get into it
so tesla we start so on these kinds
on this kind of stocks so you don't have
much data and the move is just
exponentially higher so we
need to be in a log scale guys always
always to be in a log scale
otherwise uh otherwise it just doesn't
make sense to look at it all right so
here what can we do in this kind of
crazy
extended move the only thing we can use
here so trend lines won't be very
efficient
so on this kind of stock you always need
to be in a logarithmic
scale okay so you don't have that much
data and the move
was just a crazy up
so first we look at weekly charts
and we are kind of trying to know if
this move up that we are having
here is finished or not sorry
this move up here so let me go to the
baby
we want to know if this move up is
finished or not all right so the
move the move up that has started in
may 19 is it finished or not so we only
have one thing we can use here
is uh so fib extensions i'm going to
show you how but illiot wave principle
once again for those who don't know what
is eliot just subscribe to the channel
and click on the link below
and subscribe to my newsletter you're
going to receive a free video where i
explain everything about
idiot all right so basically moves up
develop in five waves as we know
so here we're trying to find uh five
waves
up okay so up here we go
and to me it looks actually
that the move that has started seems
much lower
so one two
three because the three is the most kind
of
extended one
so i could put the three at a different
place that's true
you know i can do like this
this would be a valid count but then if
this was true we would have here a
correction
which we don't see all right we see the
market trading higher we see the market
quite strong and supported by a lot of
buyers
so this looks to me like if the fifth
wave were done he would have had a
zigzag all right or a flat correction or
anything
this all right this could look like a
flat correction but i'm sorry guys but
this is going higher
all right this is going higher even the
the macd is going lower so we have kind
of a divergence here
uh this is not corrective this is not
the end
of a strong move up like this so i
rather believe
that we're having something like this
and that we are still in our fifth wave
all right
[Music]
so the kind of target we could have
here so for this i'm going to use fib
extensions
all right so fib extensions is just
telling me
that the the next wave
has like a relation with the wave before
that was in the same direction so here i
measure for example
the so i'm gonna do fib extension from
the third wave
which was the last bullish wave to the
fifth wave so i take like this i do like
this
all right and here if i measure
the third wave and i apply this
projection to the fifth wave
so i need to find the bottom of the
fifth wave which is here
then i have this all right and this is
giving me actually
very nice levels and for example the
most
likely one is the golden ratio one so
it's the 61.8 percent
so i think that if this is correct then
we're gonna have a final move up
uh before this whole move up has been
complete
to the 600 to the 600 level
and then we're gonna have some kind of a
correction
that would lead us probably so let's get
rid of this
okay two so i'm gonna use fibonacci this
time
retracement and not projections all
right so from here
to here if i'm correct and we go to the
600 level
then the correction would lead us to the
50
315 for example but we already corrected
here last time so maybe we would go to
the
61.8 retracement so
i don't know this is very bearish uh but
those are the levels that uh
would actually target if i took a short
position starting from 600. so
this would mean that tesla had some
issues because this is a massive
loss a massive drop but this is how
things work all right
when you have such an extended move it
needs to correct so one day or the other
i think we might see this levels coming
all right let's go to apple now apple is
very interesting because we have more
data you know
this is a leading stack of the s p 500
for a very long time
and and i think it's interesting to look
at what happened for so once again here
okay i'm already in the logarithmic
scale i need to do this
otherwise the chart doesn't make sense
and so here i can analyze the move
that happened since before the bubble
the tech bubble
burst in 2000 so once again for this
kind of stocks that are just crazy
uh on the upside you only you can't
really
use trend lines you know because trend
lines are for
linear moves for exponential moves you
need to adapt and what do we have we
have five extensions and we have idiot
all right
so here i'm gonna use illiot wave theory
and i'm gonna apply this to where i
think
this is the beginning so it looks like
here we have a beginning all right
because this is not really something we
can have a nice count but here we can
this is flat all right for like 20 years
this is going up so this so idiot waves
work very well for markets that have
growth
you know because it's just telling you
that
the markets that growth follow patterns
all right
like you can see in the nature you have
a lot of fractal patterns everywhere
in what is growing for example trees
shells
flowers so on and so forth so everything
that is growing
develops into fractals and idiot wave
principle is very nice to kind of
uh measure all this development so here
this is what we're going to do we're
going to measure
this we're going to measure how apple
grew
in the past 25 years so this
is a one no doubt on this then zigzag
one
two three this is a two then the third
wave where do we put it
should we put it here should we put it
here should we put it here
nobody knows but i have some clues
because the third wave is the most
impulsive one all right
it's the uh strongest one the most
impulsive
so where do you see things fading here
i think that this is very impulsive but
it's not
long enough all right if i put it here
it's
longer than the first but not that much
if i put it here
then it's actually
longer still very impulsive
so i think this is correct i could put
it here as well
but then i lose uh you know strengths
it's
the the slope of my growth that
basically the growth
is lower so a third wave has a very
strong
growth so i would put it here i would
put my four
here and my five somewhere here i don't
know
finished or not let's see so this is on
the monthly then
what do i want to know i want to know if
the fifth wave is finished or not so i
go to the weekly
i go to the weekly and i'm gonna try to
kind of see if the fifth wave is done or
not
all right so to do that same thing again
starting here so one two
three four five somewhere here let's put
it a different color
all right so here the third wave
is definitely not the the strongest so
i'm not
very sure of discount maybe i would
change it later
maybe actually we have a third that is
here
a false here and a fifth there
that's possible but i'm gonna show you
why i did this
why i think it's like that
because look how so then i zoom in again
i go to the daily so again we applied
the top down
approach we start from the monthly time
frame
and slowly we go to the weekly daily
hourly
to understand where things coming from
you know to have
a global view of what is happening
and then so here
this is my fifth wave
and this one i put it here actually
because i have checked this before
and i saw that here we have
one two three
four five that is beautiful all right so
when you have something beautiful
something obvious you need to take it
into account this to me
because okay why you gonna ask me why i
didn't put
three here and something like this it's
not
a valid count because this in the third
wave a third wave is impulsive
this is corrective all right you cannot
put the covet crisis
inside the wave you know for sure this
especially not in the third wave so this
cannot belong to a third wave
this must belong to a false wave all
right
that was very correct if by the way this
you can see
this is not an impulse it's a diagonal
and diagonals usually
occur in the final move of impulsive
moves all right it's a diagonal
why because in an impulse
and once again i'm i'm explaining
everything about it
in uh my video on idiot waves that you
can have
if you just subscribe to my newsletter
here
bam how's it crossed
i'm checking if the force wave entered
wave 133 because this is
not allowed in in an impulse
and so this is not an impulse because
here enters this territory here
it trades below the top of wave one
so this is a diagonal and diagonals
usually occur in
the final moves of extended moves all
right
so guys this all makes sense to me
so what i'm saying then is that
it looks like we are in a fifth wave of
a fifth wave of a fifth wave of
a very of a 25 years
move up that would correct probably
quite badly
let's be honest but is it finished once
again let's go to the four hour start
time frame so now i want to know if the
fifth wave here is down
so i put it too far
okay so this is my force
and does it look complete this one
does it look complete can you count five
waves
let's try
so
i can do one two or one two it doesn't
really matter
this is definitely a three all right
because it's
strong it's clean okay you can do it
like this
but then once again this is not
corrective enough like for tesla like we
said for tesla after this you need to
have something
quite bad happening this looks like a
four
all right to me it looks like here we
have third wave
okay and this looks like a four like a
triangle some kind of triangle
descending triangle like we saw last
time on i don't know if it was
euro dollar or jpy up
okay here you have this triangle nice
triangle
and so if we break on the upside it's
probably going to confirm that we have a
fixed way coming and it's a if it breaks
on the downside
then we need to redo everything but i
think it's going to break on the upside
because i'm bullish on the equity for
the coming month
so i think that we have one more move up
to come one more move up
we're missing the fifth of our fifth or
fifth of six
so we need to see
how this gonna how this is gonna play
out but i would have a target
once again fib extension
i measure the third wave i applied to
the false wave
and i take the golden ratio so 150
is my level on apple
150 is my level for apple in february i
think this the s p is going to be at
37.50 somewhere around here and tesla at
600 apple at 150.
once again no nothing sure of the
in this uh if this is not true
then we have here a trend land that is
uh protecting us all right
this trend line is kind of protecting us
the moving averages are protecting us as
well we're trading above so if we
start to break the moving averages and
the trend line guys
things are going wrong probably there's
gonna be a rush for dollar
equity are gonna go lower um
and then we need to uh reassess
everything
but we're not there we're bullish for
now even if yesterday was
a bit bearish uh i think that
is just correcting a little bit and
we're gonna go finally up
all right if this happens where are we
going i don't want to scare you guys
but we need to have a look at it
so for to do that we use
so we we're gonna retrace this whole
move up and we're gonna retrace it where
to the
number of fibonacci as usual so i use
fibonacci where is it
here i measure the lowest point with the
highest point which would be at 150 in
this case
and where do we go at 93 or 75
so those are my targets if we have a
correcting move
we're gonna probably go to uh
so 75 means we're losing 50 so basically
it's gonna be like a strong move down on
on the markets if apple loses 50 guys
things are not going doing well so maybe
this is what is happening
next year i don't know i hope not
i hope we're gonna be able to save the
economy after this
crisis but we are very extended
we are very extended on the a lot of
assets
on the even the bitcoin is going is
going crazy you know everything
basically that you can put your money on
and that had a return in the past years
uh we have kind of a lot of liquidity
getting in
and this to me looks a bit like a bubble
but i think the bubble is not ready to
burst
we still have some more upside but one
day or the other it's gonna burst
that's how things work that's how
babel behave actually that's it for me
thank you very much for listening i hope
you enjoyed this uh technical analysis
on the text i will do maybe commodities
next time
um and if you guys have some positions
on this
uh be very careful my advice are only my
view
but what i can tell you is use a tight
stop loss
so you're gonna be safe and stay close
to show i see you guys